Congrats on this thank you what I love
about this is that it's a Christmas
holiday themed show that is full of
dysfunction because that is so true to
life yes correct
it's that kind of what drew you to this
project as well oh definitely I was just
super super fun so for whatever
combination of reasons I have a profound
soft spot for any Christmas movies and
all that kind of and Christmas specials
like Christmas Christmas always a big
deal in my household I could come by
pretty honest because it's my mother's
favorite day of the year and so you know
we have some pretty serious Christmas
traditions and a large part of that is
watching all this Christmas specials on
TV every year and so you know the chance
to do one look I can't go back in time
and be in you know rude I could never be
rude off even if I was alive when it was
made because it's animated but I I yes
it's just super neat to get to do one
that's also just legitimately cool and
funny and compelling and yes it's and
for me to get to work at home in
Montreal is it's pretty special
like you said cool like this is a cool
show Denis Leary and Elizabeth Burke oh
it's pretty good that's pretty cool they
sang your praises oh yeah they love work
as you yeah the feeling's mutual
yeah like what has it been like working
with those two on set because they're
phenomenal
there and they're legends you know and
yeah I grew up watching both of them you
know and so it's yeah you can do a lot
worse than having them as parents man
and they're just uh yet no it's it's I
grew up watching both Elizabeth and
Dennis you know and they're they're sort
of legends and and in addition to that
like that would be cool into itself but
for them to be as pleasant to work with
as they are and you know we get along
like a house on fire man
and we make each other laugh and you
know like I say some hokey like we are a
family I real family to like nothing
like that but it's just like yeah I've
enjoyed hanging out with them you know
and and every day I get to show up at
work and get to work with people who you
know make me laugh on who I'm
legitimately sight to see and and yeah
it's it's that's that's been incredibly
easy and you know so so it's an honor to
work with them it's also super fun yeah
like I said to that - it's not every set
I think we both know every set doesn't
have the vibe of those two coming and
you know enjoying each other's company
absolutely absolutely it's it can be it
can be dicey and awkward and and it
hasn't been either of those things
mercifully so it's the Moody's so I want
to know is there something around
Christmastime that makes you Moody I
hope some people hate shopping yeah yeah
definitely
I abhor shopping i I hate I hate
shopping when it's just friggin March
and there's no stakes whatsoever you
know let alone when all of the Western
world is doing it at the same time you
know and inevitably I will something
will fall through the cracks you know
and they I get into this sort of zombie
this is ignore like a kind of a ghost I
missed this Specter I've ordered so many
things on Amazon and so many packages
have come in that I ultimately forget
half of what I got everybody the worst
is when I get a bunch of stuff and I
don't know which thing goes to which
person you know because I just I just
sort of parcels come in for three weeks
straight and I just kind of accumulate
them and I still haven't learned the
lesson every year regardless my mother
and my wife tell me I should start
wrapping early and I might my argument
and reply to them as always no it's my
tradition I always wrap all of my
presents on Christmas Eve but really
it's just laziness and and
procrastination and you'd think I'd have
learned my lesson by now but I have not
yeah well you mentioned your wife
congratulation
I'm really a Chiari that's really
exciting you mentioned your mom loves
Christmas growing up so is there a
tradition that you will bring into your
house with your wife now maybe from your
childhood
there are some that I would like to but
I'm not so I'm not so so bold as to
presume that I can just assume that
anything I want to do in the house I
share with my wife is something that can
happen so no like I I every year since I
was a kid we've put on a Christmas story
when we decorate the tree and now we've
got two trees you know one a mom's house
and one at ours and yeah B III I
wouldn't mind watching Christmas Story
twice every year
final question easy fill in the blank
the Moody's is going to make your
holiday season that's a very I don't
know why this is the one that's I'm
gonna die on I say one more give it to
Moody's is going to make your holiday
season ginger ale
no I I think even more fun
you